I feel like this happened so quickly
hello everyone I'm Alana ocharlalazad
and we have finally reached the end of
the first season of The Last of Us on
HBO I feel like this happened very very
fast
um and I have thoughts so I guess this
episode where I do this like recap will
be a review of the finale but also how
it ties into the whole season so you can
count this as my whole season review
spoilers of course
so the finale is all roads leading
forward to
um a pretty divisive decision that I
think was handled both very well and you
know there are just some changes that I
would have liked certainly don't think I
could do it any better and my overall
thing with this show is I feel like it's
such a good adaptation of a video game
it gets to the heart of the video game
in a way that most adaptations
absolutely fail to I was so apprehensive
going in and so worried that they
wouldn't deliver the core experience of
the Lost of us and I really feel like
they did this is such a well-made show
so well produced very well written
brilliantly acted I really hope that all
of the people who were critical of Bella
Ramsay understand why she was cast now
because there was so much criticism uh
thrown her way and I feel like she just
did a beautiful job so for the most part
very happy glad to have watched it I had
a great time my lingering concern is one
that I think has been with me through
all of these episodes which is I just
wish it were a little bit longer so the
that we had a little bit more time with
Joel and Ellie I do think this episode's
showing us a little bit about
um Ellie's Origins was interesting
Ashley Johnson who plays Ellie plays um
Ellie's mother which was actually really
cool to see and I think she's a
fantastic actress she's just incredible
and seems like such a good person from
everything I know about her as well so
happy to see her there and so we opened
with this very frantic childbirth scene
where somebody is giving birth while
fighting off
um an infected which is probably the
least realistic thing that's happened in
the show at this point like definitely I
like a well I doubt it but okay and she
is bitten before severing the umbilical
cord which is how
Ellie in theory um at least this is what
it leads us to believe becomes immune to
the infection but because Ellie's mother
tells Marlene
no I cut the I cut the umbilical cord
first
nobody actually has that information I
think it kind of dampens the choice it
makes it
um replicable if that's the means to get
the Cure
then
Ellie actually didn't need to be killed
we just needed to have another woman go
through that exact same thing during
childbirth which is almost equally awful
but still a possibility
um it it removes Ellie being the most
important thing there which kind of
strange it's a very very tense scene
it's beautiful moline's Choice there The
Exchange that she has with Ellie's mom
was all very powerful a great opening
sequence regardless of the outcome or
the implications I thought it was very
very very powerful
very gripping
harrowing start
um especially when it's right next to
Joel and Ellie being very happy very
very peaceful at the very start of the
episode
because I guess they don't really know
what they're walking towards and of
course we we have the two of them
slowly heading towards actually seeing
the fireflies to wrapping up this
journey that they've been on for so long
again it doesn't feel that long the
giraffe scene was wild and I know that
that giraffe was real but for some
reason it really looks like CG I was
like is that because they had to like
digitally edit out the reflection of the
blue screen on the giraffe it really
doesn't look real I don't know why um
but that was there of course we had
Ellie needing to get a ladder and then
somehow seeing the giraffe and running
away very quickly I don't even know how
she saw it from inside that building to
be fair but uh Ellie's a little bit cold
stunted sort of in shock at the start of
the episode obviously as a reaction to
the violence just committed against
David and then they have a conversation
um as they're heading through a sort of
medical Zone about how Joel tried to
kill himself
and
he kind of alludes to I think Ellie says
something like time heals all wounds and
he kind of alludes to the wound being
open even post him trying to kill
himself and failing but that the wind
was finally closed by her by his
relationship with Ellie and um
I unfortunately just don't totally buy
it and it's such a shame and I do think
it's a result of the lack of time I
think that there was
something maybe to be said for and of
course this is just my opinion but
something to be said for the threat of
the infected and the clickers
Etc
um and what they do to that relationship
and I think that absence of them in the
show is something that seems like it's
very easy to do like it's a show about
these people we don't actually need the
infected and a lot of the part I would
agree with that but I think that the
infected ad tension and they require the
two to really look after each other
um pretty much consistently there's more
desperation while they certainly had
run-ins with very bad people
um the lack of hostility from the
outside world I think probably did make
their relationship a little bit less
believable
I just ultimately don't feel like they
bonded all that much I think that Ellie
was very harsh withdrawal a lot of the
time Joel was very quiet in response to
her a lot of the time
um The Twist almost being in this
episode where like Joel is suddenly
extremely friendly
um still feels a little bit abrupt I
think that in the amount of time that
they were allotted maybe it was like HP
was like only Nine episodes in the Nine
episodes I think they did a fantastic
job of showing the relationship between
these two characters
I just wish we had had a couple more
episodes I think just a couple more or
at the very least it doesn't feel as
strong as it does in the game for me
personally that bond between the two of
them and again I think it's way easier
to bond in the game when you have to
yourself look after Ellie you yourself
are protecting her or she's protecting
you you know when Ellie actually starts
shooting people
um she takes people down and so because
you are so active in that story and the
way that that story is told it's so much
easier for you to care about Ellie I
think they've done a very very very good
job
um with what they had and I think this
is a brilliantly made show
and I wonder if you know I wouldn't feel
this way if I couldn't stop comparing it
or if I could stop comparing it to the
game but it's so hard to do that
personally for a game that so many of us
have loved for so long it's really hard
to just like separate the two but I just
think you know so as we get past that
conversation no it didn't feel totally
owned to me but I still I still
definitely liked it and then um inside
of firefighter where we learn that uh I
think that was this was new to the show
and it's not said in the game Marlene
says Ellie didn't know she's calm she
had no idea and I'm always like we
really should have asked her why did
nobody you just ask her you feel like
all this would be a lot easier if she
had just been asked I thought that him
taking out the fireflies
was beautifully shot the silence and the
music and basically watching him run
through and execute people in order to
save her that was very very well done
and I think it is really interesting
seeing it versus playing it because
playing it you feel compelled to do so
you go whoa whoa no I can't let her die
you feel you feel that way you know like
it's so overwhelming because we have
such a sense of we just we just feel so
protective of Ali by the end of the game
so I don't think it hit anywhere near as
hard in the show unfortunately maybe
because again it's a more passive
experience but I I don't know um that
Rampage he's going on was really well
shot and I thoroughly enjoyed seeing him
turn into the monster when you know he's
in Theory been protecting her from the
monster this whole time but it
definitely didn't hit
quite as hard as I would have expected
and I wonder if maybe it would have
helped if the Firefly seemed a little
bit more passive or kind like even the
two that walk him out of the building if
they hadn't been more passive if they
had been more friendly more jovial
um rather than seeming like fedra or
like Kathleen's men because they still
seem very armed that maybe would have
made it more brutal but I think it's
also um a very odd shift for Joel to go
like he almost acts like he's a SWAT
member here which is something we've
never seen of him before it does seem
kind of sudden and they say all
throughout the show Joel's really
violent Joe's really violent he's got
this violent past but I don't feel like
we actually see all that much outside of
the torture scene we don't see it that
often so it is
um pretty abrupt and shocking but again
that that was all stuff that I really
liked I really liked the way that was
shot and I also appreciate that they
don't paint it as him doing something
heroic in fact in the show I think he
comes off looking even worse it's also
just so unbelievably selfish like I love
the ending of the last place I think
it's brilliant it's so selfish he's
saving her because he couldn't save
Sarah and he's probably been haunted the
whole time by what happened to Sarah and
and what he could have done differently
and he's saving her just as therapy for
himself it is really really interesting
and lying to her about it and not caring
is just such a selfish thing to do when
you're almost dying to save someone it's
so interesting it's such an interesting
concept but I think the massive
differences between Sarah and Ellie in
this show all also sort of hurt that a
little bit like I feel like Sarah and
Ellie in the game look a little bit more
similar act a little bit more similar
not entirely but a little bit more
they're very very different in the show
Sarah and Ellie are way different people
way different senses of humor way
different tones they're just so so so
different that it's kind of hard to
rationalize in that way as well I don't
know I just um I think it's so hard to
separate the game from the show but I
just didn't quite buy it to the same
extent I would have liked more time with
the infected more threats on Joel and
Ellie more time with Joel and Ellie
maybe a couple more episodes but I still
think across the board fantastic
performances incredible set design
incredible production design just a
beautifully well-made show honestly just
makes me um wish I hadn't played the
game
they don't feel like it added a ton to
my experience except for some context
surrounding some of the extra characters
which I did appreciate but for the most
part yeah I feel like I walk away like
feeling jealous of everybody who uh just
saw the show but I guess they probably
think the same thing like people who
have seen the show and are now going to
play the game for the first time
probably feel the opposite way I don't
know so yeah I think it's probably
biased and I just can't remove myself
from it but um overall I think it's a
very very good show I think it's
fantastically well made but I just don't
think it resonated with me emotionally
anywhere near as much as the game did
and it's so hard to remove that mindset
for me personally I know a lot of people
have been disagreeing with me about this
across the board in the comments
um of previous episodes where I felt
like I said it was too rushed or I
wasn't loving how harsh Ellie was
because I feel like they needed a bond
faster and I think I stand by that but I
feel like it maybe also just boils down
to you know we only had like seven or
eight hours with them
um in the show whereas in the game it's
10 to 12. it's not a lot of time to
develop a relationship that somebody is
going to like Risk mankind over and also
again because there aren't as many
infected the risk of mankind like even
needing the Cure doesn't hit that hard
like watching the show I it occurred to
me multiple times I was like give it a
few years and all the infected will just
die out because there's like none of
them left which is probably not
something you should be thinking under
this context so that is my take on this
final episode and the season in general
um I intend to now actually go and
listen to the podcast that Troy has been
hosting the official Las Vegas HBO
podcast I think it's called and then I
was going to watch through the show
again um I'll probably wait a little bit
to do that though but it's been really
fun chatting everybody about this um I'm
still hoping some point this week I'll
do this review discussion uh on Roundup
of this final episode with some guests I
just uh a lot going on at the moment so
I haven't planned that yet but hopefully
we'll still get to that this week but
that is it for all this Last of Us
content I'm sorry for flooding your
feeds with this so much I do still have
one more stream to do to catch up to the
finale
um which will be on my twitch Channel
where we're going to play through the
last episode of the show and talk about
it sometime this week other than that
thank for watching I'm Alana I will see
you guys next time bye